what's up Wolfgang we only have three
more days to impatiently wait for
infinity war to be released I'm so
excited to see it I already got my
tickets I'm thinking about going to the
theater right now and just waiting
outside and camping out just the store
if some of y'all are planning on
dressing up to go see the movie you can
tweet me or DM me on Twitter the
pictures of you guys dressed up at the
premiere and you just might end up in a
video so today's video is to tell you
that there is a huge huge giveaway that
I will be announcing tomorrow I've been
so grateful for the support that you all
have shown me and so has the stupendous
wave so the stupendous wave and I got
together and planned a huge giveaway
that we will be announcing tomorrow the
announcement tomorrow will include what
it is and will tell you exactly what you
need to do to enter the giveaway and I'm
so excited for it I'm I'm just really
excited to be able to give something
back to you guys I hope you're excited
as well so be sure to subscribe to my
channel and check out my video tomorrow
that will announce the giveaway I don't
want to leave you guys with just a video
on an announcement so I was going to
post a new trailer that I've seen online
but then this morning the rooster
brothers released a photo on Instagram
and on the photo it was a letter that
said they're screening the movie so if
you want to avoid any and all spoilers
stay off of social media I'm trying to
avoid all spoilers that I possibly can
and I don't want to be the guy that
gives away the spoilers especially since
the movie is only three days away so my
editor thought of the idea that instead
of reviewing trailers that have been
posted we're gonna review some infinity
war memes I haven't seen any of these
memes yet so I hope they're funny and if
they're not well um well let's see if
Chris keeps his job again thank you
everyone so much for the support that
you've shown me be sure to subscribe to
my channel and come back tomorrow for
the announcement of the giveaway woof
woof okay so first name these are no
ordinary memes okay that's alright
that's good for the start okay second
one when there's a trailer description
for infinity war but not a trailer oh I
can say that I haven't done
I'm proud of that do you not worry Drac
Stannis will have to go through me to
get to you and I will cherish the second
okay that's a good one I like that one
good job Chris so okay I love this
because I love Parks and Rec yep and
pretty much that's how those movies will
be yes okay next one I can't even read
that a Mary Poppins oh that's not bad
meanwhile on Marvel Doris jerk Oh Chris
had jobs at jeopardy you didn't know
Thor is my favorite
give me another Thor one Chris I'm up
all night to get lucky oh please don't
not subscribe for my channel okay next
one how long had this pen stare at
window yes good Chris you're fired that
was Chris laughing but he shouldn't be
laughing he's fired if I can't hit you
with the hammer then I'll hit the hammer
with you problem solver this is a
surprisingly solid plan this is it guys
this is fight Thanos is the biggest
baddest villain now Marvel has ever
given us cuz of this right here
adventures 5 and 1 that's not funny it's
gonna be me tomorrow not tomorrow that's
gonna be me at the showing I like it
Warner Brothers fun isn't something once
considers when balance in the universe
but this Disney [ __ ] Marvel does put a
smile on my face that's not bad that's
not a better one to those who knew what
the Infinity Gauntlet was without Google
Bravo to you Chris remains fired Civil
War in the comics in the movies hmm it's
almost like the studio couldn't afford
more arrows yeah that's not right how
the Avengers are going to defeat Dana's
I've come to bargain help
dance-off bro language
Chris Chris might be rehired infinity
panel be like Chris yes sup how the
muscular one oops that's me
no that's me fine the one playing Peter
yeah oh dang it
not you some what if I do it is kind of
funny how they have this there weren't
Avengers infinity war who are you people
takes me back I now see why they are
called team CAF yep that's why not
because of his name but because of the
caps the marshal I'm just a civilian
starter pack totally totally makes them
in disguise Chris you have your job back
Marvel Studios Marvel movies makes you
cry about suits a tree ants and a hammer
it's true
it's really it's really true I think I
try I cried the most when Thor's hammer
broke though mule near when you have to
explain to your parents how infinity war
works and what the storyline is and they
reply with is Batman in this one gosh
I'm out of memes Chris is fired
but I could snap my fingers and you're
all cease to exist
I'm torrid time to see all the possible
outcomes
did we win any
it's a small price to pay
to salvation
Avengers infinity war rated pg-13
everywhere April 27th